[Music]  let's go  just don't make a scene you made a scene  didn't you  what is with this tension black widow  ready pg-13 get tickets  ordered on disney plus july 9th  the hell is that guy taskmaster he can  mimic anyone he's ever seen  he controls the whole army of widows  he's got to be stopped lucky us i want  to break something  you got fat smelly water  black widow wings pg-13 tickets and  pre-orders available now experiencing  july 9th  natasha you're not just a spy  but an avenger  i couldn't be more proud of you you  smell really bad  on july 9th what brings you home we have  unfinished business  the experience still fits  will be worth the wait  let's go marvel studios black widow  windy pg13 tickets and pre-orders  available now july 9.  you